[Music]
it must be great to be Batman
thank you I'm blushing super hard under
the mask Batman not preggers I can only
imagine he's going home right now the
party the night away around is my brand
and Lady activewear models hey computer
I'm home master Bruce your greatest fear
is snakes no piles No it's being a part
of a family again
no now it's snake clouds because you put
that idea in my it sir you need to take
responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising the young orphan you
adopt me I thought I was being sarcastic
hello secret camera it's the Batcave
hush oh my gosh look at the bathtub
don't touch that
the best airplane don't touch that
either the back hi jack I got a costume
I love it but it's answered just a
little tight I got an idea hmm it's
better I can only look you in the eyes
right now hi Batman no way come catch
your greatest enemies Superman is my
greatest enemy
Superman's not a bad guy and I'd say
that I don't currently have a bad guy I
am fighting a few different people I
like to fight around hi Barbara Gordon
new police commissioner it's my dream at
a police force to team up with Batman
what would that be better I hate
everything you just said nice
initialize master Billy here nobody to
back room yes we did it pretty cool
why did you build this thing with only
one sheet uh cuz last I checked I only
had one but let's go to feat the Joker
whoo we're going on a family trip I can
wear my costume too well luckily for us
you left your costume bagging right
oh no under your clothes that's perfect
[Music]
life and it starts by raising your son
I'm sorry I literally have no idea what
you're talking about
the young orphan you adopted at the
Ghana